I'm going to make an exciting mixture
makes you which we can use to to show a
number of things the first of which is
going to be the rapid reaction of a fuel
with the source of oxygen and we can use
the heat from that rapid combustion
reaction to excite other ions because
you know we could go and have a look at
an emission spectrometer and do all
sorts of elegant experiments like that
but this one is a really cheap and dirty
and honest way of seeing those different
colors from flame tests so here I've got
some sugar this is just the stuff I put
in my coffee in fact I went and got this
from our lovely sue upstairs who's an
absolute darling and you can see I'm you
know put quite a charge in because we're
going to use maybe two or three
different experiments from this makes
you today so this is the second
component of our mixture and that's
potassium chlorate and the reason we're
using chlorate is because it's got lots
of oxygen in it it allows me to put lots
of oxygen intimately close to all of the
exciting bonds that I want to break
inside the sugar we need to add about
the same volume of potassium chlorate
this isn't particularly good practice so
we shake it all up give it a good mix
now we need to test our mixture okay so
we're gonna pour a small amount of it
out on the bench onto a heat proof mat
so what's in this mixture we got sugar
and we got chlorate ions because they're
delivering all of that nice oxygen and
the chloride ions are delivered with
potassium
okay so realistically what we should see
is a nice luminescent flame from the
burning sugar with the color of excited
potassium said I should be nice lilac
colors to the emission spectrum after
the potassium - Lila so let's have a
look all right fantastic a lovely
reaction all of that energy in the sugar
and all of the carbon is being
transformed into carbon dioxide a little
bit of elemental carbon there you know
the nice suit carbon a lot of water
vapor a lot of steam and what you saw
there with all of that steam and that
energy was the lovely lilac emission
spectrum of that potassium ion so we
need to take some strontium ions and in
this case I've got a small amount of
strontium nitrate okay now I'm going to
take a small amount and put it into a
test tube now we take our excitement
mixture give it a bit of a shake mix it
all up so all of those metal ions are
mixed into all of that nice source of
carbon and energy now all we need to do
is add a little bit of energy
Wow
what a fantastic reaction really really
energetic lots of energy given out lots
of hot steam lots of hot co2 and
importantly a lovely lovely red color
from the strontium emission fantastic so
we're going to use the same mixture of
sugar and chlorate but this time I'm
going to add a small amount of a
different metal salt and this time I'm
going to use barium nitrate okay and
again I'm going to add some of my
combustion mixture now we're using the
energy of that combustion of the sugar
to excite the barium so that we can
observe its emission spectrum or the
flame test color again pour it out onto
a heatproof mats so again
so this time again we saw the same
exciting chemical reaction we saw that
same exothermic reaction lots of co2
lots of steam again but this time the
flame was colored green and this is the
characteristic Apple green which is
associated with barium salts so much
more exciting flame test every time we
change the metal we change the color so
this time we add trace and copper this
is copper to chloride so instantly
you'll see that the copper salt is a
really nice greeny blue color so this is
going to change the view of the
chemistry straight away now I'm being
very careful to make sure that this
doesn't have too much I suppose exposure
to the atmosphere because I don't want
water to get into this chemistry I want
to try and keep it as dry as possible
now this time you'll be able to see the
efficiency of that nice greeny copper
salt distributing into that white
combustion mixture now that that was
great a lovely blue flame from that
copper chloride when that really
fantastic that was brilliant
so I'm gonna make a mixture now well I'm
gonna make a series of mixtures which
I'm going to place along the bench
that's a copper strontium barium so
let's see what happens if we do all
three
that copper burns so fast so periodic
videos trickle or a copper burns so fast
you